so now that we have our text in place
for our ad we need to add our keywords
these are the foundation of your ad
group your ad has a possibility of
appearing in the top search results when
people search these keywords google
recommends starting with 10 to 20
keywords that are specific to phrases
that your potential customers may use
when searching for your product or
service google also recommends avoiding
one word keywords which if you think
about it makes sense imagine if we use a
keyword dog think of everything that can
be related to that dog health info blogs
about dogs news articles relating to
dogs videos of dogs things on Animal
Planet buying a dog cute dog pictures
hot dogs being sick as a dog getting a
little hair of the dog dog whistles dog
parks types of dogs I could go on but I
think you get the picture none of these
have anything to do with dog sitting to
avoid that chaos you can use Google
Trends keyword planner that we went over
previously to help you choose the
keywords you want to use so let's add in
our keywords after you filled out our up
I'm going to scroll down to my keywords
will go with dog sitting luxury dog
sitting dog care Pet Sitting pet care
home dog sitting in home dog sitting dog
services pet sitter dog sitter pet hotel
what to do with my dog while on vacation
and we can add more before we move on
let's hear from Chris a marketing expert
about choosing keywords and then aundrea
an AdWords expert about figuring out our
budget and bidding so we'll be ready to
launch our ad